hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the 2018 world rapid championship now
as you've seen in the previous video
Carlson had a very unfortunate game and
he actually lost two of of the first
games that he played in this
championship then he won two games and
then I was very happy when I found out
that he was paired against Andruw tank
in round five as two of them played
plenty of bullet games plenty of
hyperbolic games and as Andrew Andrews
streams and also videos are extremely
enjoyable and he will basically crush
anyone in bullet but every time he he
gets paired against against Carlsen or
you know whatever nickname Carlson uses
for the tournament he will always get
really excited and then he I think he
almost mostly always loses due to being
overexcited so I was very interested how
will as to my knowledge this is their
first over the board game so I don't
know I was really excited to see how how
he would fare against the world champion
over the board and also I don't know if
I managed to mention this in the
previous video but I did include it in
the description I don't know how many of
you actually read the description but we
will be having two days of rapid so five
rounds today the four rounds tomorrow
the games are 15 minutes per player and
you also get 10 seconds increments per
move and if there is a tie at the end of
the tournament and it doesn't matter if
there are like 15 people tied for first
place only two people are get to go into
tiebreaks and they will then play a
series of blitz games with a three plus
two the time format so that being said
let's check out how this very nice game
went andrew has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 we have d5 and Bishop to
f4 the bishops opening or the so-called
Mason attack Knight to f6 and now we
have III we have e six and now comes
Knight to f3 Bishop to d6 offering a
trade of dark square bishop s-- and
might not be to d2 and here while you
can't capture here on f4 i've never
actually
seen anyone do this similarly like in
the London system you will always have
this opportunity but white will never be
too bothered about this you will simply
play okay he captures on f4 and then you
will have a very strong outpost for your
knight on e5 B 6 and we have Bishop to
d3 we have castles by crossing and
already on move six we have a new game
so not a very standard position we have
Knight to e5 really standard move
centralizing the knight c5 and now comes
Queen to f3 Queen to c7 by column and
now c3 so andrew has a very nice center
here the pawns are on dark squares the
bishop is a very nicely placed here and
the light squares a nice attacking
formation at some point maybe maybe even
h4 h5 h6 could even be be played Bishop
to a sex by Carlsen offering a trade of
bishops and you don't really have a
choice other than to trade here you can
go to C - that's kind of going in line
with the Queen and c7 and if you go all
the way back then then black is the one
actually preventing you from cancelling
so Bishop captures Knight captures and
now castles we have Queen to b7 and now
comes Knight to g4 you don't have the
option of trading bishops here because
if you capture them first white will you
ruin your bone structure here in front
of the King pawn captures and only after
Queen captures on f4 will you have to
worry about your king said weaknesses
but white will have a much better
position so after an IG 4 we have Bishop
back to e7 and now comes Knight captures
an f6 with check Bishop captures and now
a very nice maneuvering move by Andrew
Knight to c4 the the point is of course
pinned as the Queen on b7 is on on
defendant and the knight can now come
either to e5 or even to d6 if if needed
Bishop to e7 by Carlsen taking away the
d6 square now from the night and now
Knight is read directed at e5 and here
seems to be one of those positions where
it's actually okay to play f6 and cross
and plays it immediately kicking away
tonight we have Knight back to c4 as
this is still a pin
Queen to d7 now getting out of the pin
and now comes night back to d2 but now
comes see five and even though you can't
capture here you don't actually lose a
piece if you play characters captures
now it seems like you lose a piece but
you don't Queenie to attack the knight
that is awkwardly placed on a 6 also
undefended
but after capture screen capture Celia
will capture here and then the the 3
point is very weak here Bishop g5 can
attack it a much better position for
black so after he 5 Bishop to g3 and now
comes C capture Sun d 4e capture some d4
and now e4 Carlsen manages to put this
point all the way to e4 Queen back to e2
and now comes Knight to c7 so the knight
is now being Rieman over the back into
the game
f3 by Andrew and now comes f5 cousin
still wants to keep the attention in the
center also ff4 and III can be played it
should be very nice for black so Andrew
first was Bishop to e5 and now this f4
will not come with an attack on the
Bishop Bishop to d6 now offering a trade
we have captures captures and now comes
F captures on e4
we have D captures only for this is now
a protected passed pawn and Knights the
c4 this comes with an attack on call
since Queen we have Queen to e6 and now
comes in 95 and this is now a very
strong night it's not yet a monster
night as well with some maneuvering
calls and can still maybe maybe get this
Knight traded off for his knight on c7
in a couple of moves but still an
excellent out was for the knight Knight
to d5 by Carlson and now comes a 4
now we have a 5 by Crossin and rook 81
so White's pieces are fully mobilized
Carlson has yet to finish development
and he's his idea is bringing this rook
to f6 maybe maybe use h6 to attack the
White King ended then the other rook
will also come to FA to be doubled up
but first came to h8 to somewhat improve
the position of the King we have Queen
to f2 and now comes rope to f6 s plan if
you go e 3 here
immediately this is possible but the
problem is after the Queen moves you can
go f4 and yes these pawns are now very
nicely advanced but white can simply
push c4 and now the the defender of the
f4 pawn gets kicked away ninety-seven
rock captures and the blacks valuable
pawns are getting destroyed now
so after Queen to f2 I will have roof to
have six preparing to double up on the F
file Queen the g3 by Andrey and now
comes look f2 a rook a to f8 Queen to h4
and now Queen to e8 and here
interestingly it's cousin was down to
some five minutes and the Andrew was
down to less than a minute and I know
what you're thinking what why would this
be a problem for Andrew he's basically
every day he's below 1 minute on the
clock but it's different here it's over
the board and you are facing the world
champion for the first time over the
board the Queen is now very useful in
defending is in some situations perhaps
if this rook would leave the 6th ranks
ideas like 9g 6 check would be possible
but also the queen is now attacking the
a for pawn so here Andrew decides to
defend the pawn he plays the rook to e1
and now the Roop has left this e1 Square
and the the route being an e1 was an
essential part of Andrews defence as a
black could never really execute f4 as
as long as the night is on e5 there is
nothing to protect the e4 pawn so you
will never be able to push f4 because of
rook captures on e4 but now that Andrew
played route to a 1 cross and
immediately seizes the opportunity and
goes f4 and now this is already somewhat
of a problem for white we are nice to G
for attacking Carlson's rook rook to f5
and now rook a back to e1
now if Queen captures of course you will
trade it for for the very nice central
pawn rook to h5 attacking Andrews Queen
Queen back to f2 and now the problem is
you you can play III here if you play e3
then you get to Knight captures on e3
and now all of these exchanges are
impossible because after rook captures
you will see white will simply be down
up up upon ok black can capture an a4
but you
not to be able to recapture due to
checkmate on f8 so after Queen to f2 we
have looked back to g5 by Carlson and
now comes Knight to e5 and now it seems
Carlson definitely blundered at the e4
pawn as there's a really no good way to
defend it and here you could capture an
a4 but as Andrew was so low on time and
it's not well what Carlson played is is
an excellent move rook captures on e5
the instead of going for the a4 pawn so
giving up the exchange but after
captures captures now with less than a
minute and the clock andrew has to deal
with these two very strong pawns
rook to d1 and now you still can't go
III if you go III immediately then you
get Queen to F 3 with a double attack
here against the knight and e2 doesn't
help you because of rook captures and
after pawn captures rook here yes you do
get another Queen but now King chapters
and the Queen keeps defending the rook
the material is equal and the white is
all ok here so after rook to d1 cross
and instead of III goes f3 and when you
see this with less than a minute on the
clock it's it's not not at all
comfortable Crossing is hoping for G
characters on f3 and if this is played
now e3 is a big problem because now you
kind of have to go g3
if you if you go Queen e2 to block it
then Knight to f4 wins on the spot after
Queen moves e to your attack both rooks
and it's a game over so after f3 we have
Queen to g3 by Andrew offering a queen
trade but first Knight to f4 with
similar ideas now of course if you
captured an idea to check picks up the
Queen
so here Andrew tries to set up a little
trap he plays the rook D to e 1 now
nicely to check will be met with rod
capture so now again you cannot capture
because of rook to arrow captors and I
faced with checkmate
but here Crossing simply played Queen to
c5 a very nice move that comes with
check the white king is in check and
also conveniently if needed
the queen is also guarding the rook on a
fate so here Andrew blocked we have
Queen to f2 and here after F captures
and g2
andrew is in a lost position but it was
it was actually in this position that he
lost in time so his time ran out very
very ironic for for this particular
individual but yeah that there's nothing
really for you to do you cannot move or
capture with the Queen as the Queen
spindle you would have to capture lights
and see five and then why it has this
nice efficient tube or an in-between
move that is G captures on f1 this will
come with the check you can bring the
Queen or rope into the game and after
king captures you will play B captures
here and you will just be up a whole
night and it's it's a game over for for
white so yeah after this F capture Sun G
to enter tank lost on time and across
and now after losing two games in a row
won three games in a row and before I
forget I did prepare this this is a
these are the standings after round five
from the chess results calm so as you
can see with four and a half points I
haven't been able to follow all the
games or all most of the game says there
are simply too many players in this
tournament but I'm gonna check out which
are the nicer one so I'm gonna prepare
them for for tomorrow morning let's say
but as you can see after five games
three of the players with four and a
half points holidays a few is a
grandmaster from Iran very strong player
he won the he actually won the
tournament I organized for celebrating
my 200,000 subscribers milestone and we
chess then Jana Palmilla she Dmitry and
raking ball three hundred four and a
half points and then but they have
gehrman it's interesting the better app
it'll echo said that although it seems
that this gentleman is a very very
strong player that he never heard of him
I might have also never heard of him but
yeah I'm sure that we're gonna be seeing
him a lot as you can see he's not even
he doesn't even have a title you can see
that all of all of them have a
grandmaster title and he has no titles
but I'm pretty sure he's gonna give a
title soon then also with four points
chakra mom Yerevan cow
Kamsky Donnell dubov Alexandra Zubov you
young ye Anton Caribe oh I don't know if
you remember two days ago I mentioned
that if you ever because there was a
position that I mentioned core above
played against the von Schuch and he won
that if you ever have a chance to check
out a game by horrible that you
definitely should do it and very glad
that he's up there with the leaders with
four points then Boris Gelfand
a Gregorio Perrine son and Shirokov
Peter Svidler Nikita with Cuba then
David Anton and also with four points
madam Basia touch of Croatia and other
players with three and a half points and
so on and so on I think Magnus Crossing
is currently at 76th place but yeah I
mean it's not everyone is writing like
Oh an unbelievable terrible start for
Magnus Carlsen but it's not that
unbelievable even though he is the best
player in the world he's not a blunder
proof I mean it happens to everyone so
at some point in some tournament you
cannot win all games so I don't think
it's that big of a deal but yeah we'll
see we'll see how it goes and definitely
if you have any games from this
tournament that you yourself enjoy use
the hash tag suggestion and we're gonna
check them out so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I again invite
you to join my subscribers video the
link to it will be in the description
below and the email you should use to
send me your videos and photos will be
right below that and also below all of
that will be a link to a very well
peculiar YouTube video that I invite you
to check out as its I'm very interested
in what your opinion is about it I will
put it in the description under a very
peculiar video so feel free to check it
out it's very short a minute and a half
but yeah I really do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon with
some more content from the 2018 rapid a
World Championship thank you all and
I'll see you soon